I will jump right in then and I want to
just ask you first of all this movie is
physically insane how beat up are you
Chris after this movie yeah I was super
pretty
it pretty paid up I it's still
recovering movie I mean during the film
it was like it just running on
adrenaline and we had the busiest
schedule the most intense schedule and
every day the action sequences we were
shooting all day long it's hot
exhausting we got home and we never
rehearsed the next you know I fight
saying to the next day but yeah yeah the
the adrenaline and excitement and
enthusiasm that you know we were doing
something pretty special and unique was
just kept it running and didn't ever
stop to think of anything else but it
yeah but fair share injuries and scrapes
and bumps you want to survive you do
exactly as I say
being a father play into this whole
thing for you because in a sense you're
protecting a child and you see them like
a paternal instinct kicking yeah look at
you know anytime you considered roar
upon something that is truthful and then
that's always the aim and something you
can relate to having children myself has
certainly made that there was a direct
sort of connection there I also it was
you know we had a two or three-month
shoot and my kids didn't come with me
you know I was sort of back and forth a
bit but mostly away from them and I've
never done that before that was that the
hardest thing you know in itself but it
certainly added you know lions to my
sort of any vulnerability or pie no
feeling from that mmm-hmm and there's a
hell of a twist in this movie I just
want to throw that out there everybody
of and I also want to ask both of you I
say I'm including how did shooting in
Bangladesh and India the madness of the
urban atmosphere in those countries
really add to the movie because you feel
how close people are yeah
well that was our goal from from the
beginning once once it was decided when
Joe Russo had in the script that it was
taking place in that part of the world
you know because we wanted to show a
side of the world that maybe Western
audiences haven't seen that much and
that's the reality of that part of the
world it's very densely populated we
wanted to be true to that and I don't
think you could have made this movie
anywhere else and have been true to the
story and and it was you know the energy
just the the visceral nature of it kind
of the yeah it's palpable you can smell
it you can feel it and hopefully they
came across in the movie and it really
elevates that I think that's action
set-pieces because you're in amongst it
I mean there get Chris and then randeep
hooda night fighting with cooked up
going in between them like it's tried to
capture that chaos as much as we could
Chris how are you we're doing this
virtually and you know the last time we
would be at Avenger sitting across from
each other how are you dealing with this
whole thing and what's it like doing a
junket from from home I'm assuming yeah
um look it's kind of it's kind of nice
to be home you know and and normally
we'd go from country to country country
and the spices you know a two-week
period and each it's insanely exhausting
I don't miss the travel I miss the sort
of interaction with people certainly but
the changing time zones I'm quite happy
to do with that but I'm sort of just
enjoying that the time at home with the
kids and and and not having a schedule
laid out in front of me and and you know
not sort of knowing what's coming
there's a bit of anxiety with that but
also kind of refreshing and to sort of
just be at peace with that and just be
in the moment and day by day and have a
positive attitude are you handling
homeschooler are you into that at all
right now
yeah that's that's a wish I had a
positive attitude about that that's not
myself not very good it's it's you know
I'm under gosh yeah Sheen tactics are
improving that you know it's it's like
three hours of that and then 20 minutes
of actual school work all right I feel
you trust me
hey Sam I want to ask you that because
you guys are one of the few movies that
are actually coming out this summer they
put you in blockbuster position how does
that feel and in a sense you've been
able to capitalize because you have your
film in the can
yeah I mean we were very fortunate you
know nobody can see something like this
coming that's gonna have such a global
impact that was surprising to all of us
but you know we were in a very fortunate
position because we did we had finished
the movie and we were targeting that
April 24th release date and we stuck
with that just because it was you know
you felt right and we but we hoped that
we can hope now then this this crazy
time that we can bring people a little
bit of escapism you know there's some
entertainment something something new
and fresh a different perspective on an
action film maybe and just provide
people with entertainment in these times
where that's more important than ever
Chris you do these bananas work out so
have you like ramped things down for a
minute are you taking a little time off
as you're sitting at home or are you
still deep in it I know the app is up
and booming yeah I um I was kind of
going crazy for a minute just you know I
had so much time in my hands and I
probably over trained and was like well
it got really exhausted and now just
kind of a bit more sort of functional
stuff and and and trying to you know
give content to the app and think it I
think it creative ways to train at home
with with minimal equipment to sort of
give that advice to people and um that's
been a really really fun journey to you
know being able to sort of connect with
people all over the world by the app and
then give them again a sort of an outlet
some of that sort of pent-up sort of
anxiety or what have you
yeah that's cool all right guys thank
you so much and enjoy the rest of your
day good luck guys hey thanks quick
[Music]